my name is Lars Ulrich and I feel
psyched
about being Conan O'Brien's friend you
know what I'll take it I'll take it I
mean uh that's pretty cool Psych is a
good word psych does not come up on on
the spell checks on your iPhones until
you've put it in like 9 000 times but
psyched is a big word in my vocabulary I
like that you you broke the artificial
intelligence of Apple to compliment me
we do we do what we can keep apple on
their toes not that they needed from us
first of all not too long ago I go to
see I'm like a lot of us I'm friends
with uh with Jack White so I go back I'm
backstage at a Jack White Show and there
you are and you're just there as a fan
and I'm there as a fan and we got to
chat a little bit and it was just cool
to see you out enjoying music wherever
Jack White is playing if I'm in the same
vicinity I'm I'm always there I love
Jack have loved him obviously going back
to the white stripe days I think he
personifies that sort of edgy rock and
roll that's uh becoming lesson less of a
big you know thing these days I mean he
he's in the studio he makes records
impulsively and and it's just oozes a
lot of the same elements of kind of
danger and impulsivity and not quite
knowing you know one of my favorite
things about him is that he never has a
set list he just makes it up and as it
goes along and so I'm always watching
and you know he's do this song and then
song and then he'll yell back at the
other guys in the band and now we're
gonna do this and then it's it's yeah
they have to be on their toes
they don't know what he's gonna do and
um the a word that comes to mind that I
a lot of my favorite artists embody this
word Restless I think that's the word
that comes up with me with you can tell
he's just fidgety and he needs to go and
make I gotta make something now and I
gotta do this and I gotta do that and uh
so it was just nice to be backstage and
there was a lot of cool people back
there it's you know we live up in San
Francisco obviously as you know and when
we come down to LA
you know it's always oh my God look at
these pack stages they're so-and-so and
they're so and so it's always fun to run
into other creative people down here but
but Jack is really uh one of my maybe
top five all-time musicians I I love him
and whether he's doing you know uh his
own stuff whether he's doing the
background tours whether he's obviously
back in the day with white stripes or
whatever he's just such a great
artist uh unpredictable artists always
it's interesting to see where he goes is
so inspiring uh and on top of that he's
a really nice guy always uh welcomes you
you know we're in Nashville you know a
couple years ago
um we we based out of Nashville for two
weeks and played sort of the southeast
of of the states out of Nashville and we
were there for two three weeks and
um he just come over to the house let's
go to dinner come to Third Man you go to
this house and there's a bowling alley
and you're hanging out and hey look did
you want to jam in the in the back in
the studio I mean it's it's a he's very
abrasive and I love it sounds desperate
to me I'll be honest with you
you know it sounds like Jack doesn't
have enough to do and Jack if you're
listening and he's a friend
you know
sad you know I'll tell you uh I know
what you're saying but but
I'm gonna get a text from Jack about
this we can text him right now let me
call you after you gave him his number
well I'll tell you what and Jack if if
you're hearing this you know I love you
and nothing but love but for a guy who
supposedly doesn't have a phone he's a
pretty you know he's a pretty engaged
texter yes you know so I'm not really
I'm not really quite sure how that works
out
or whether you know it's just got a
computer you know that he texts from
whatever also He's So Pro uh vinyl vinyl
vinyl he's got the uh every time I go to
his house all he does is play CDs that's
all he does
and I'll go like hey we'll do what can
we check out that vinyl record he's like
no I'm not gonna listen to that he
said if you want real quality CDs and
then it's like more blue oyster cults
soon MP3